[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
tony
[ __ ] them
[Music]
taco
tuesday
[Music]
big news
tomorrow's hearing is postponed
[Music]
because of technical issues i don't know
if i believe that either it's hard for
me to know what to believe
i'm not saying there's some big
conspiracy theory here but my guess is
is that the select committee wants this
news to marinate
in the public and on social media for
just a day longer also the other issue
is probably they're getting prepared
for the doj witnesses not just jeffrey
clark but donahue and a few others and
that's who we're supposed to hear from
is trump's doj
you know the funny part is is we have
not heard from one witness
that is a democrat not one not [ __ ]
one democrat has testified
under oath all republicans they're like
oh this is all a setup it's all the
democrats there's no republican they're
all republicans who are testifying
every one of them
all the footage that you're seeing all
republicans all trump administration
officials all the witnesses that have
testified in front of the select
committee rather they showed up because
of the labor pains or not
they
they're republicans they're trump
humpers they're part of the
administration that tried to steal away
our vote that tried to commit a cheeto
dust kangaroo coo
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
this is bias
i mean if you mean bias that republicans
don't get to torch this committee
with their antics and their crooked in
their crooked ways yes okay then it's
bias
you libtards and your your bias truth
yesterday we find out there might be
more federal crimes
that an election fund is [ __ ] it's
all [ __ ] there's no election fund
there was no legal defense fund for his
election not no
he was stuffing the pockets of him and
his family maybe to keep their [ __ ]
mouth shut i don't know who knows who
knows what they were stuffing their
pockets for i think we may find out in
due time it's gonna take a little bit
though
i think that was one of the most
significant things that came out of
yesterday
is that donald trump was defrauding his
supporters i mean we knew that right we
knew that
we knew the grift was real
but we never had really the the hard
evidence or the lack of the evidence
that existed that this election legal
defense fund existed or some [ __ ]
well yesterday we found out
with the committee having the power
subpoena that no
there is no such thing
and 250 million dollars was drifted from
his supporters not to mention the cr the
the biggest credit card fraud
in our nation's history
that donald trump and his campaign
placed on his [ __ ] supporters
now regardless of whether this turns
into uh criminal matters or you know
some kind of consumer protection matter
this is still an issue
and really
if if some of the people who gave to
donald trump because it the word was
that kimberly guilfoyle received 60
thousand dollars for i don't know having
rudy giuliani fart on her or something
i'm not real sure
something about an introduction or a
speech or who the [ __ ] knows who paid
what when
it was all a grift it was all to put it
in their own [ __ ] pockets the entire
time
but if that doesn't piss some people off
i mean they didn't piss me off i don't
give a [ __ ] i think it's funny
i think it's [ __ ] funny that those
dumb [ __ ] gave money to donald
trump thinking that he would use it for
what he said he was going to use it for
you are a stupid [ __ ] bastard if you
give money to a trump and and think that
they're going to use it for what they
tell you they're going to use it for you
were a dumb son of a [ __ ]
i mean it's not hard to go back and look
in history
at donald trump with his properties his
casinos the unif trump university for
crying out loud
the [ __ ] eric trump's charity
they were stealing from their charities
come on this isn't difficult it isn't
[ __ ] rocket surgery you dummies
of course they stole your money we've
been telling you this for a long time
they stole your [ __ ] money
but some of these dummies are like oh
it's all fake news here here's some more
of my money
[Laughter]
here's some more money i mean they were
running [ __ ] they've been running
campaigns to to to get more donations
for their legal defense fund
all week
all week
because these january 6 hearings are
going to produce criminal charges
probably
not out of the committee it's just going
to garnish public opinion
to where the department of justice
is very confident that not only can they
prove their case
in the court but they can prove their
case in public in the public sphere
because that's part of it whether you
like it or not
whether you like it or not johnny depp's
trial wasn't about money it was about
johnny depp getting his career back it
doesn't matter what side you're on
it was about the court of public opinion
and
unfortunately in this country we have a
large number of people not a great
percentage but a large number of people
who are still believing the grift and
boy these republicans are really leaning
into this oh my god they're terrified
dinesh d'souza steve bannon and all
these republican congress people holy
[ __ ] they're leaning into oh this is all
fake
it's all fake i thought they're they're
they're making up audio and blah blah
blah
i mean just on and on and on it goes
they're terrified they're [ __ ]
terrified
that not only is the grip going to come
to an end here which is
very detrimental to the republicans
but some of them may be criminally
exposed
members of congress criminally exposed i
mean hell they liz cheney all but said
scott perry was begging for a pardon
and there were other members in line i
think we're gonna see that
in the court of public opinion let me
tell you something
this [ __ ] idea
that
this this the trump family
is taking [ __ ] money from their poor
broke ass supporters and paying 60 grand
for giving an introduction and i guess
it was the introduction on the ellipse
i'm not sure who the [ __ ] knows who
really [ __ ] cares in the first place
but you remember the video kimberly
guilfoyle dancing in the tent you know
she was doing her little stripper dance
or whatever the hell it is that she
always does
when they were watching on the screens
before they went on the ellipse and
and tried to get the mob to go to the
capitol to do their bidding to overturn
the government so they can remain in in
power and keep drifting
through the government
she was excited and that day
you know looking back it felt like until
yesterday it felt like she was excited
about the people going to the capitol
and smearing [ __ ] all over the walls
hanging mike pence arresting nancy
pelosi and making donald trump the king
but now we find out she was excited to
get about get she was gonna get a 60 000
payday
if you don't think she's that [ __ ]
shallow you haven't been paying
attention she's that [ __ ] shallow she
was dancing and excited because she was
getting paid 60 grand to go on stage and
introduce
an introduction she was excited she was
happy about that why wouldn't she be you
would be if you got paid 60 grand to
introduce someone for two and a half
minutes
no one's made that much money since
stormy daniels one minute of fame
with donald trump
really kimberly guilfoyle should feel
ripped off
i don't know
maybe
surely he didn't last more than a minute
come on
with stormy i mean i'd love to have her
on to talk to her about it
i would
not not not in detail about the one
minute just you know how long
the time and how you know she said it
before
but i digress
kimberly guilfoyle should be mad that
she only got 60 grand this is a grift
what the hell is the difference she
should have been paid 200 what the
hell's the difference
donnie's rich right and and donald trump
rich he doesn't need that extra money i
mean he's a billionaire he's a great
businessman they always tell you in the
comments
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
they are some broke [ __ ] they
are some broke [ __ ] and i don't
mean just financially broke i mean
morally broke these people are [ __ ]
bankrupt and they have been for years
and people were yelling and screaming in
2016 and people wouldn't listen but
that's the point
don't you see
don't you see the gop is bankrupt and
they loved that donald trump was their
leader
because they could lead him down all
kinds of paths of bankruptcy
and come out shining on the other
[ __ ] side
and now and now that the evidence is
coming out that it wasn't very [ __ ]
mortal
and it was crooked as [ __ ] and possible
crimes were committed and other
republicans were complicit in it oh it's
all fake that's all [ __ ]
but they loved it they [ __ ] loved it
they were he was hit their golden goose
of grift
why do you think they keep going with
him because he's the golden goose of
grift he doesn't care he's shameless
they're shameless they don't care they
don't give a [ __ ]
they love the idea of being able to
raise money without consequence
on lies
course
but this hearing tomorrow has been
postponed
they say for technical issues now i
don't know if that means they're trying
to get their clips in line we've seen
yesterday during the hearing and if you
haven't watched it go watch it go file
the mind as touch youtube channel you
know we we produced their
live broadcast forum on thursday and
yesterday we'll be doing all the
hearings even if they add hearings we're
going to be covering them live
but yesterday right before when we were
broadcasting the news dropped that uh
bill steffen
the the former campaign manager of
donald trump the current campaign
manager of liz cheney's primary opponent
decided that he wouldn't show up now
some people said it was a legitimate
reason or it wasn't but whatever the
committee bought it and they they were
managed
to tell bill steffen's story without him
being there with the clips that they had
from his testimony
and that's kind of the point here of
videotape testimony see you can hear
this out of the republicans mouth i have
the trump allies mouse themselves like
bill barr
jared ivanka
jason miller rudy giuliani as drunk as
he may be
that's the other bombshell we got
yesterday is rudy's a drunk yeah no [ __ ]
sherlock
no [ __ ] [ __ ] are you kidding me rudy
drinks are you kidding me holy [ __ ]
this is like figuring out that he runs
around farting on people of course he
[ __ ] drinks of course he's a drunk
haven't you seen borat
i mean he's not only a drunk he likes to
tuck his shirt in way down below his
balls
while lying on the bed
come on he was playing with his dick in
that movie come on he wasn't tucking in
the shirt you don't tuck your shirt in
down below your balls
i've never i've never had anyone
give me the advice hey if you just you
know if you tuck your shirt in
underneath your nut sack that thing
won't come up and if you lie on the bed
doing it it's much easier get the [ __ ]
out of here
he was playing with his dick he thought
he was gonna have sex with that woman in
that movie that's what he thought
just like rudy giuliani was drunk on the
night of the election and he thought
trump should go downstairs and declare
victory
because he's a [ __ ] idiot
he's a [ __ ] bonehead
we found that out yesterday that rudy
giuliani is a drunk bonehead no [ __ ]
sherlock
but the piece of news there was that
trump was running around the white house
trying to get someone to tell him what
drunk rudy would tell him
and he could only get drunk rudy to tell
him to go downstairs and declare victory
even though you shouldn't do that
they were all telling that you probably
it's probably not man it's not a good
idea
he did it anyways because rudy giuliani
told him he should do it that's all he
needs that's all trump ever needs it's
just one person many people are saying i
told rudy to tell me this thing and now
many people are saying it
[ __ ] idiots
it just can't get any stupid
more stupid right
it's going to
these hearings are going to display more
stupidity if you don't think these doj
hearings that that's been postponed for
tomorrow
where the doj officials from trump
it's gonna get really [ __ ] dumb
i mean really [ __ ] dumb
there's not gonna be anything
intelligent coming out of the [ __ ]
mouths of these people in this testimony
it was really [ __ ] stupid to believe
that somehow
somehow
joe biden had stole the election and
there were boxes of ballots even bill
barr was like look how the [ __ ] do you
think they get ballots from a polling
location to where they count them how
the [ __ ] do you think they [ __ ]
teleport them
of course they put them in [ __ ] boxes
and truck them to count them you stupid
bastards how else do you think they get
there
in boxes in [ __ ] trucks there's
thousands of them
really [ __ ] bonetted [ __ ]
that they don't understand that there's
processes in the election
when you're counting and each pre-scene
each
each location each jurisdiction
has different processes but they kind of
remain the same
on how they count and it's particularly
in detroit when billboard destroys
this idea
that somehow moving boxes to one single
location was somehow fraud bill barr had
to point out hey in 2016 it was the same
[ __ ] dummy
and really frankly in 2020 you got more
[ __ ] votes now bill barr's no [ __ ]
hero here
because he only he'll only say that [ __ ]
under oath behind a closed door
even though he's he know he knows it's
going to be recorded and played
on national television he'll only say it
under oath behind a closed door that's
it he won't say it out in public you
[ __ ] coward
and that's the thing that we have to
[ __ ] come to grips with here
is that the gop and all these trump
lackeys they're just [ __ ] cowards
they're cowards because they love the
grift billbar loves the griff too hell
he's living off the trump grift with
this [ __ ] book
of course he loves it they love the
trump grift
they know he's dumb they know he's
stupid they know he's a [ __ ] buffoon
but they love the payoff in the end why
not
60 grand to go on stage and introduce
someone [ __ ] i'd have been dancing and
excited too
yeah she wasn't excited about the coup
she was excited about the fact that hey
we're gonna make donald the king and i
get to griff forever hell
sixty thousand dollars for two and a
half minutes
what else did we learn yesterday
we learned yesterday that roger ailes
if he would have been alive may have
been able to tell trump to go [ __ ]
himself i don't know i doubt it
i doubt it i doubt that the results
of him calling aaron fox news calling
arizona would have changed if roger
ailes was alive i doubt it
i doubt we'd be in the same position i
think we would have got the same
testimony yesterday
because again they love the griff that's
why fox news does what they do they love
the grift
250 million bucks from a bunch of
toothless [ __ ] rednecks
that they get the stuff in their own
[ __ ] pockets can you imagine
can you imagine the power of money oh my
god
how exciting would that be that all you
got to do is send out a thousand
preset emails and people just dump money
in your pocket because you're a [ __ ]
racist and a fascist this is perfect and
these people have none the wiser that
we're stealing their money
and they believe us at every turn no
matter what we say can you imagine
he wasn't drunk on the power of the
presidency
he didn't give a [ __ ] about that he
didn't even know what the [ __ ] that
means he has no clue he's a [ __ ]
idiot
but he knew the power of his grift he
knew the power of people typing in an
email sending that sumbitch and people
sending me money and then i can steal it
from him cause that's what he did he
[ __ ] stole it from him he said yeah
i'm going to use it for my legal events
oink
and god knows what he was paying for i
think we're going to find out
congresswoman zoe lochren
indicated that we're gonna find out what
the [ __ ] these payments were and who
they went to and how much
and the beautiful part is they were able
to subpoena those records
because of their power
to tell the [ __ ] truth
to tell us the american people the
[ __ ] truth
and of course speaking of truth over on
true social they won't even allow people
to post about january 6th won't even
allow them to post over there
even their platform for free speech is a
bunch of [ __ ] just what bill barr
said it's a bunch of [ __ ] [ __ ]
this shouldn't be surprising and really
um out there you know people are upset
and mad about this but we really
honestly we've known about this right
most people have been in tune to this
we've gotten most of this stuff in news
reports there just
isn't any hard evidence or the lack of
evidence to back up some of those
reports it's just hearsay or
our sources say
our sources
well here's the evidence here it is the
[ __ ] that we've been knowing here's the
[ __ ] evidence of why we've been
knowing it
i mean again it's not [ __ ] rocket
surgery
to know that donald trump is a [ __ ]
grifter and a buffoon
it's not difficult to understand that
i mean it's right out in the open jesus
christ they stay yelling the quiet part
out loud he released a 12-page memo
can you believe that [ __ ] 12
pages he wrote a tweet
i don't know how much of it i haven't
read it i don't give a [ __ ] really i
don't care what it says i think
prosecutors might care what the [ __ ] it
says i don't give a [ __ ] what he rants
about on 12 pages
the only thing newsworthy is that he's
losing his [ __ ] mind and [ __ ] in his
diapers down at mar-a-lago
any anyone who was not guilty would be
staying the [ __ ] quiet and listening to
their [ __ ] lawyers at this point
not him yelling screaming at the top of
his lungs
trying to create chaos trying to create
a narrative
to where he can justify his dumb
[ __ ] crooked ways
and it will continue folks it's going to
continue and it's and you should enjoy
it
yes that's what i'm saying you should
enjoy it this is [ __ ] fabulous
because honestly us of those of us who
have been pissed off about these
[ __ ] trying to subvert our
democracy and steal our vote away
we've been saying this [ __ ] all the time
the whole time we've been saying this
[ __ ]
exact evidence that is coming out now
it's the dallas proof is in the [ __ ]
pudding
but we even
we've been cramming the pudding down
america's throat for [ __ ] years
but it's time to get to the evidence get
to the facts and the best part is that
we get the spot to people who don't give
a [ __ ] about the truth here's what i
mean by that you've seen these people in
the comments already the [ __ ] trolls
are thick
i go
it's all fake they're making it all up
none of it's real don't believe your
eyes when they show you video testimony
under oath
of the people who were most loyal to
trump
it's his [ __ ] daughter his son-in-law
his attorney general who who [ __ ]
buried the mueller report for him
to hide any crimes that he had with
russia
what are you talking about
bill barr was your [ __ ] hero dinesh
d'souza you piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah i'm calling out dinesh d'souza he
was like oh bill barr hit the muller
report yay for him great fascist i love
that kind of nazi
and yesterday he's mad that bill barr
told the truth under oath behind closed
doors and bill barr didn't tell the
truth under oath because he thought it
was a good thing it's because they have
bill barr's records
you understand that right you [ __ ]
dumb [ __ ] dinesh d'souza
you understand that they have the the
notes
of bill barr they have his [ __ ] notes
as evidence he can't say anything that's
other in those notes he has to testify
to those notes he has to say the words
out of his [ __ ] mouth that reflect
those notes because if he doesn't he's
possibly
exposes himself to perjury
because he would say something that is
contrary to the evidence the hard
evidence that they have
that's why bill barr said in the first
hearing i i remember three meetings i
recall three meetings with the president
about the election being stolen and the
reason why he recalls three of them
because he went back and looked at his
notes that they subpoenaed that they got
and there was three noted three meetings
in there about that subject so he had to
testify to that fact
because if he wouldn't he would have to
explain why his notes were wrong or why
he's [ __ ] lying
under oath
it's that [ __ ] difficult folks
and it's not hard to tell these
[ __ ] what what is what in your
comment section or in your thread or at
the church or at your [ __ ] family
dinner
you gotta slam dunk these sons of
[ __ ] it's time it's time that we say
no enough's enough of the [ __ ]
partisan fake news [ __ ]
you're not gonna get away with that
anymore
if you think liz cheney is some kind of
[ __ ] liberal you are a stupid you are
dumber than donald trump if you think
liz cheney is on the side of the
democrats are being paid by the
democrats or some kind of [ __ ]
socialist commie you are a dumb son of a
[ __ ] you have never done you have never
never done any research on darth vader
or darth vader jr ever in your life
she voted against voting rights folks
she does not believe in women to have
bodily autonomy she is no god damn
freedom liberal for sure
she just wants power back and she wants
to oh she wants to own the republican
the gop power inside our democracy and
without our democracy she doesn't get to
be in power
jesus christ it took liz cheney 190 days
it took liz cheney
190 days to come to the floor of the
house
and call the big lie a big lie
190 days it took her to go to a house
microphone and say that on the floor now
i'm not saying i'm not saying she's
doing her duty because i think she is
upholding her oath here
adam kinzinger the same way
for whatever their motivations are for
the democracy whatever it may be whether
it's to save face or save their party or
be the leaders of their party i don't
give a [ __ ]
at this point
but for anyone to say there's no
republicans on this committee you are a
stupid son of a [ __ ] and that's why the
american people are not going to believe
anything these [ __ ]
trolls and your comments say because no
one is in the belief that liz janey is
some kind of democrat liberal juror
george soros bought
antifa you are stupid that is ridiculous
on its face
that a chaney is a democrat
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
that's the best part about
having her on the committee
is she is the enemy
she is the enemy of the democratic party
for sure
without doubt
i mean everyone wants to hail her as a
hero here but again she's upholding her
oath to the constitution i believe
now regardless of what her intent and
her motivations are she's doing it
and what pisses them off the most
what pisses them off the most
is they know she's going to be
successful that's why they're terrified
of liz cheney that's why they took away
her leadership role
that's why they they act like she's some
kind of democrat liberal now
oh look at that [ __ ] lib liz cheney like
come on
they're terrified of her absolutely
terrified of her because she is kind of
scary
she's kind of scary benny thompson's
like well i don't know if we'll give
crim a referral she's like [ __ ] that
[ __ ] hold my beer
we're gonna take these [ __ ]
down
you don't think you don't think the dna
of dick cheney darth vader lives inside
of her come on
she's re she's already dug the hole for
trumpism she's ready to throw dirt on
top of it
and bury it once and for all and for
good in this country
and i think we're going to hear a lot
from her in these upcoming hearings and
i'm happy to hear from her
i'm happy to watch who normally destroys
liberals destroy trumpism
it's fantastic we should enjoy it
we should enjoy the facts collect them
up
make sure you have them in your twitter
feed as little clips
to show your uncle earl and your aunt
edna
that what they've been believing the
money they've been giving has been going
to total utter
100 percent horse [ __ ]
or as bill barr puts it
[ __ ]
i'm glad you could join us we got a ton
of new listeners thank you for joining
us not just here at the podcast but also
on our live coverage of the hearings on
the midas touch and the midas media
network
over there on their youtube channel you
guys know we broadcast every single
weekday monday through friday noon
eastern 11 central on youtube twitter
twitch follow us
follow us on youtube do not miss a thing
you want to subscribe to the channel you
don't want to miss anything also go
follow us on
twitter at tonymichaelspod at the tony
michaels and i am gabe sanchez speaking
of gabe sanchez
hey
good morning
good morning yeah it is a good morning
and you know we got a little bit of news
i'm actually excited that the that the
hearing's postponed
it gives me it gives me a little bit of
extra sleep you know
wednesday thursday i i don't care i know
i know i want you to not get sleep here
you really
actually i think i i don't know if
anyone knows this but after the
broadcast yesterday i talked to gabe for
a few minutes he's like hey man i'm
gonna go take a nap
yeah gabe gabe had a nice weekend with
his friends so he had he had to take a
small nap but no here's why i keep in
mind that it's 6 a.m
when we start for me
and i have to be up before that so i was
waking up at like 5 15 5 30.
i i will tell you here's the reason why
i'm excited this this hearing is
postponed yesterday when we were on air
we were on air and the news was oh my
god oh my god this guy's not it's going
to be 45 minutes late and i was like oh
i'm excited i get 45 minutes extra to
talk yeah we have 45 extra minutes so
now we get not just today to break this
down we get tomorrow to break it down as
well before we go to the next hearing
the other thing that i think is
significant too is yesterday when the
news dropped that bill steffian would
not be joining the committee uh hearing
with the subpoena for whatever the
reason rather it was valid or not yeah
but what but here's what i'll tell you
is that
um i think they it did a better and i
don't know what you know in hindsight's
always 2020 but i think with the clips
that they played of his testimony with
his own words in that way i believe it
was just as good it really drove home
this idea that the big lie was a big lie
it was created by donald trump and his
brain and all the wackadoos right it was
all the [ __ ] wackadoos all the team
normal as right right right framed it
they were saying the [ __ ] that you
normally say right like no you haven't
won yet you haven't lost yet we
shouldn't admit either way right we
should wait we should wait but nope
team whack-a-doo with drunk rudy as
their leader
is it was like no get out there and say
you won because that's the only way to
do it just like he told everyone else
because he's projecting it right he said
this in these last primaries just go say
you won yeah just say well that's very
you know that is very much the the trump
routine right i mean he even told uh
yeah in the primaries which with uh
with you know oz he goes just say you
want you know because then they can't
take it you can't they can't take it
away you say you won then then the other
opponent just goes okay that's just not
how it works also they're like yeah you
know what hey guys stop tabulating the
count just we can just quit counting
right now
he said he won so we're just gonna take
his word for it he won you know um
but yeah i mean even we broke down after
with uh with david and rachel and we had
a good conversation there we talked
about how
you know they they did a really great
job in yesterday's hearing by
identifying the clippable
uh bite sound bites right stuff that's
marketable right right exactly like as
soon as big massive dumps hit or uh
inebriated rudy giuliani like those
things were trending right immediately
they knew exactly yeah and i was like
team normal team abnormal like that's
like everyone was making associations
here and there and it was trending no
throughout the day and i'm sure it's
probably still a bit of a trending today
but yesterday it was like as soon as
that cl that was said people clipped it
people tweeted it people hashtag it like
it was out there like a wildfire and
that's the johnny depth herd type stuff
right exactly that we need to get in
front of people right because that's the
goal here because
most people who have been paying
attention either one way or the other
either they know what is the truth
they're just waiting for these facts to
be laid out
or they absolutely are delusional and
and are entrenched in in the q anon type
conspiracy theories that would get them
down the road where they believed this
[ __ ] [ __ ] just like just like bill
and said in his testimony today
these people were out of their minds
like they were out of their minds the
sydney pal the mike flynn rudy giuliani
i think it was even uh stephen miller
who had a who had trouble admitting that
um that rudy was wasted he's like hey
yeah he was drunk yeah yeah yeah
it is one of those things uh
where i find it funny because that whole
administration was like don't need to
wear masks and then he's in there
looking like bane and he's like you know
oh yeah i said stephen jason miller yeah
yeah
uh stephen miller is jo he is uh um
no no no he's um
uh uh the original vampire oh that
creeps out from the ground you know
there's a very eerie similarity between
them i mean them and rudy giuliani they
share like this similarity as they creep
from one of the floorboards but um yeah
drunk rudy again you know you said
earlier in the show which is like no
[ __ ] like we all knew it right you know
like it's not hard to know that rudy
giuliani is right we are uh yeah
nosferatu there we go yeah somebody
somebody uh messaged it that's what i
was thinking of is the original kind of
vampire um but yeah rudy giuliani like
no [ __ ] the guy's drunk the guy's all
over the you know he's five he's like
five fingers deep on like whiskey
telling everyone i'm not drunk i'm not
i'm not drunk you know and it's like we
clearly know that you've had happy hour
and then an even happier hour after the
fact right
where it's like
no one no one tucks their shirt in under
their balls right i don't know i mean
it's like things it's like you're
tucking it into your ass like you're
just getting it in there
that's not how it works that's not how
it works i mean i mean it it it may be a
new thing that i haven't seen yet but
i've never had the advice like hey if
you don't want your shirt to pull out
just tuck it in underneath your nut sack
you know kind of like you're stuffing up
a bone
also there are uh elastic clasps that go
from your socks up to your shirt to make
it tight like it so you don't have to
right so you don't have to be tucking it
in or like you know going under or
whatever you want you know
he was playing with his dick he was
playing this oh we all know that we all
know that that's the whole thing is we
knew rudy was drunk but the piece of
evidence that we didn't know yet like we
didn't i and you could surmise this
you'd be like surely he was running
around the white house trying to find
anyone who would tell him just go down
and admit that you want or just say that
you won even if it's a lie just go say
it but we didn't know
until yesterday that it was the drunk
rudy that was the only one that was
willing to say yeah go down there and
say whatever the hell you need to say
buddy yes you know trump is like should
i go down there and say i won and rudy's
like yeah you should you should go down
there and say you won because that's the
thing trump's always like people are
saying because i told one person they
repeated what i said back to me and now
i'm hearing it yeah well
rudy is the guy like you know it really
shows you it's like with alcohol like
all social barriers have been broken
down
your confidence level you know to your
own like discredit is now like way
boosted so you're like oh all we got to
do is save one and we won and that's it
he's the guy at the party who's like
yeah you know what you should do you
should drive home drunk that is who rudy
is ruby's the guy who would be like oh
you know what even better i'll drive you
home i have only having two
two drinks tonight and i'm totally fine
i can do it oh
cool just ignore the [ __ ] leaking out of
my right exactly like maybe you know
maybe it was like excess alcohol that
was leaking and the toxins like get me
the [ __ ] out of here right i don't know
what it was but rudy giuliani is that
person who will
under her the influence give you the
worst advice ever
absolutely well here's the other thing
is can't you see the scene set the scene
here where he's trying to search for
four seasons to set a press conference
and he's drunk on his phone he probably
doesn't really know how to operate the
phone in the first place yeah and he
goes to google he types in four seasons
right yep and he's autocorrected to
close this area right and he's like all
right there we go and he calls him like
just pushes dial and he calls him books
the conference he's wasted he doesn't
know until he gets to the next day like
what the [ __ ] is this right there's a
dildo shot there and there's a bit we're
at a mowing place like imagine you know
going back to that moment uh
you imagine
can you imagine rudy giuliani or like
the people the interns who like booked
it or had to follow up and be like they
show up and like oh like do we have the
right spot like this is a
this is just an abandoned parking lot
next to a landscaping area
okay and they call him up and he's like
i booked it i booked it must be your
mistake and he tries to blame everybody
else and like just put a bunch of trump
pen stuff up behind you guys we'll make
it work
and it's like
all right man you guys are
you you you like you guys committed to
the bit like congratulations but holy
[ __ ] you guys could have cancelled you
guys would have gone off to the street
you gotta could have gone anywhere else
meanwhile the people at four seasons
landscape were like i mean there's a lot
of
things
yeah they're like this is great you know
inside they're like [ __ ] live
tweeting like this [ __ ] [ __ ] is so
crazy these [ __ ] it never fails with
these bastards it never fails
with these ninka poop nazis because i
believe that's truly what what is
happening here is just hitler adolf
hitler would be totally disappointed in
this band of misfits right oh like they
would be like he would be like what in
the [ __ ] you couldn't you couldn't
execute this coup to go down this is
ridiculous like even i did a better job
at a vineyard right i mean the level of
within the trump administration i mean
the republican party as a whole like the
incompetence level's like the bar is
real low
but the level of incompetence only
within like that tight group of the
trump administration
setting world records man let me tell
you no i know well speaking of
incompetence did you know that herschel
walker invented the wheel the internet
and electricity did you hear this did
you know that herschel walker also
invented cte yeah he did and crt he
invented that phrase exactly
ctr but you know they had to turn it
around right right he's invented almost
everything and i mean honestly he's the
world's greatest inventor i don't know
that he's he's been he's been a fbi
agent he's been a cia spy he's also been
in the first world war second world war
i'm sure he he survived the vietnam war
and now now he's a chicken guru who
invented chicken he invented chicken i
mean he invented it he invented chicken
he invented a lot of things uh you know
the smash burger he was the inventor of
that he was the inventor of modern
cinema you know okay movie theaters
cinemark
amc
all of those places did he come up with
the game of football too
i mean
why do you think they're called pigskin
like he one day he was on the farm he
made bacon and it said why don't we wrap
this and pump it with air boom boom
throw it down a field boom i could touch
down i could run
touchdown
this is really dumb so he so so the news
is is that herschel walker admits did he
say this on a podcast what the [ __ ] did
he say this i forgot that he was an fbi
agent and he was a policeman or some
[ __ ] yeah he was like a deputized
policeman or something like that but i
mean it goes it's very on brand right he
was like i was top one percent of my
class and it's like nope no you weren't
you didn't even graduate yeah
and then you know there are the other
things about the chicken business right
or not taking the ppp money but he did
take the ppp money you know there's all
these things where it's like
he could just not talk and he would be
doing
way way better than he is right now
because that then at least he wouldn't
be caught in a lie by claiming something
and then someone going wait actually
i work there that i've never seen that
guy in my life
i don't even know who this [ __ ]
is but you know the story that i think
other than him claiming a bunch of [ __ ]
you know it kind of reminds me of
madison cawthorne
[ __ ] that's just provably it's just
you're able to prove that it's just
[ __ ] categorically false right like
just with a little bit of research you
can say that this is categorically false
yeah but the thing that gets me the most
is the story where someone comes to
herschel walker house and he pulls a gun
on them it's like what the [ __ ] yeah
yeah what in the hell well not only i
mean not only his friend but his
girlfriend at the time right and he
would do like the russian roulette thing
to build trust with people like what the
[ __ ] are you doing yeah what do you mean
like you have to look at this and say
there is something there is an imbalance
that's happening here whether it's cte
right or something else
by the way how many hits you know you
know
for people that don't know you are the
virtual roommate of his son christian
walker you've done a lot of videos about
uh christian and i think he he he
doesn't i don't know he probably doesn't
like you even though you're oh no he
hates me he hates me i mean speaking of
which actually
actually this shirt yeah
uh me and a friend made this shirt in
response to christian walker oh yeah and
and then we uh we used the proceeds and
we donated to different organizations
that uh he hates oh that's fantastic
yeah yes do you hear that christian if
you're listening out there we really
appre gabe appreciates your content to
be able to raise money off you to give
to organizations that you probably
despise that's fantastic i love that i
love that you know if you're gonna
we might as well we might as well raise
money and give it to people who we say
we're gonna give it to you because gabe
i think that's actually the biggest
piece of news that happened in
yesterday's hearings was that
250 million dollars
was [ __ ] lifted from trump supporters
which is not surprising right that's not
surprising to any of us yeah but there
was no the thing that really was the
piece of evidence that we really already
knew
is that there was no election a legal
defense fund there wasn't one that you
even you even made a video long before
like yeah yeah so after that
yeah yeah so for the context for people
so you've got this the official uh trump
defense election fund right and what we
discovered yesterday is they were
sending up to 25 emails a day
to people to donate right like help me
help me fight help me defend help me do
this help me do this right
and what you find out is that when it
was originally released and they had
launched it
um
sixty percent went to uh trump's uh pack
that he created which was called save
america the other forty percent went to
the uh rnc now neither of them and i'll
say in the in it'll scrub it in the
video but neither of them
uh have to actually use the money for
what they say it's basically to pay off
debts
and so what we discovered yesterday and
i think that number of the 250 million
was
uh
was already revealed earlier about how
much money i mean there was also
millions because there's been there's
been reporting on this but the problem
is because the legal defense fund
doesn't exist the reporters couldn't
find it so it wasn't like they they
didn't they couldn't tell if it didn't
exist they just didn't know where it did
exist if it did but with the subpoena
power of the committee they were able to
use their subpoena power to find out
that this did not exist there is no
record of it where the media has trouble
you know they don't have that same
subpoena power to get these records
right right exactly so sometimes the
facts are elusive it's just what they
don't know is what they don't know yeah
but now the committee doesn't now they
know that there wasn't one right right
exactly which is the uh that's the
that's the big deal right there which is
there was there was never a fund right
yeah they were going to use it for what
they said so well here sounds like fraud
when when did you well it is fraud uh
when did i make that
you know when you when you first posted
this video because i want to give people
context of
uh because you literally at the very
start say donating to trump's election
defense fund
um the name that they outed yesterday
that was not real and the reason why you
took that name is because that's what
was appearing in emails correct
yeah so that's what was appearing in
emails at the time um okay let's see
and because you lifted that that
phrasing from the emails that were
happening at the time when he was doing
this um your that phrase appeared
yesterday in the hearing
because they were lifting it from the
same emails that you were lifting it
from because the claim was made that
they were going to be using this money
for legal defense to win the election
like that's what they were telling the
trump supporters like hey it's all a lie
joe biden didn't win i won it's a total
fraud give me money and we'll just prove
it right and then they're like yeah
we're going to take that money and we're
going to pay kimberly guilfoyle to
introduce someone right we're going to
we're going to pay 60 000 i believe it
was right well you know i it's unclear
at this point we don't have a whole list
but um representative lochran was on cnn
jake tappers and maybe we'll play that
clip uh where she is exposing
um the amount of 60 grand that was paid
to kimberly guilfoyle to give an
introduction on the ellipse uh
apparently i think that's the the case
there it was like two and a half minute
introduction is what she got paid for
now if you remember gabe she's dancing
in the tent right before yeah
they're dancing they're watching it's
the whole thing and some people are
think that they're excited about the
government being overthrown but i think
what they're excited about is the money
the check that they're about to get yes
so i made i made this video i released
it on tick tock
when probably twitter as well on
november 15th
2020. so this is this is from
from the time of the big lie when he's
spinning the big line right after
and the big thing to note here is that
in the video i'm using what was at the
time
it's outdated now it was 60 percent it
was 60 40 split between trump's pack
you're talking about you're talking
about the disclosure when they actually
gave the money right so if i gave a
hundred like i do in the mold yeah if i
give a hundred then it would be 60 bucks
for trump's uh pac save america and 40
would go to the rnc
now within uh
within two weeks
they changed it
they and they didn't tell anyone
they changed the the the uh the legal
kind of copy that that you're agreeing
to and it went from 60
to 75 percent so now 75 was going to
trump's uh new pac which was save
america and then the 25 was going to the
rnc
so that's uh you know everyone you know
and then also they're using um
a a thing that is you know they they
counterpart to uh
uh act blue is win red and red red is
the republican donating platform that
you go through however the big thing
that got trump in trouble and others but
mainly trump because there were so many
uh so much money that had to be returned
you're talking about the credit card
fraud right so their credit card fraud
that came in is because they were auto
enrolling people in recurring donations
without people
just without the proper yeah you can do
that you just have to have the proper
disclosure
that's the thing it has to be these are
things that have to be opt in you can't
automatically opt in for them you have
to opt in
and you that way uh you can't get
tricked and so that right there is cause
for fraud because people say well i
never agreed to doing more than just one
donation well it's actually the biggest
credit card fraud that we've ever had in
our country right
and so i mean that just yeah that just
tells you you know how
that just tells you i mean that is
completely on brand for companies and
his crew and his [ __ ]
uh cronies where they will take as much
money as they can get away with before
people realize it and spend it
and put up their their their treasure
chest uh or their trove of money to to
fight you know all these cases which had
no legal merit because it was all based
on fantasy
and they even brought it up yesterday
which is all these cases they had they
had a segment in the video where they
said like
these are
individual uh
quotes that are coming from judges that
are throwing and dismissing these cases
because there's no actual case to them
there's no evidence there's no actual uh
proof of fraud right and so it's just
it's the grift you know right well it is
the great grift make make america grift
again so let's let's watch your video
from
november of 2020 about the election
defense fund this is fantastic going to
president trump's election defense fund
i'd like to make a donation to stop
buying from stealing the election
excellent how much would you like to
donate 10 that's a start i guess twenty
dollars fifty dollars i'm sure you can
get more to help daddy trump well
money's pretty tight since we lost our
business due to coping uh yeah that's a
bummer and we didn't qualify for trump's
stimulus check listen are you gonna
donate or what well i guess i could do
100 justice once great
wait why are you splitting the money up
like that well 60 goes to trump's new
leadership pack save america for the
recount no it's used to pay off trump's
campaign debt or whatever he wants
really okay but what about the rest the
other 40 goes to the republican national
committee which isn't required to spend
on the recount at all but i just gave
you a hundred dollars none of that goes
to the recount you said you were mega
for life i am maggots
now shut up and give me more money [ __ ]
[Laughter]
shut up and give me more money [ __ ]
because that's basically the that was
the crux of it right yeah that they kept
emailing and emailing you and they're
still doing it today i even sent a post
i even seen a post that someone said
they took themselves off their list like
through an unsubscribe and this week
they started to appear oh yeah emails
which is that's a big issue and i
wouldn't be surprised if people because
you can sue for that
you can sue because that's spam and
there was a there was a law that was
passed that protects us as consumers
um against against uh companies that are
trying to spam us and so basically
uh if you if you unsubscribe like having
evidence be like i am subscribed from
this list i didn't resubscribe and then
they continue to contact you you can
actually take legal action so who knows
maybe there's a class-action lawsuit
against
uh
the
trump's superpac or whoever's behind
these emails
but
there is um there is case for it yep
well you know speaking of legal action
uh about things have you received a
cease and desist yet because i have not
i haven't received a season decision i
have a video that you're not
i have not i figured you'd get one first
before i got one but yeah yeah i well i
figured when i went to bed i was like
maybe i'll get a cease and desist in the
morning
never got one never got one who knows
maybe i got lost in the mail i don't
know what you did get was a a link to a
video that seemed very similar it seemed
very very similar and i'm going to call
you colbert we're not going to show it
because you know what you know the
shittiest part if we show his [ __ ]
version of this video which is after you
made it but if we show stephen colbert's
version of this video they'll [ __ ]
get a copyright thing on us and all that
[ __ ] and they'll [ __ ] block it out of
the youtube video give sons of [ __ ]
you know i don't know if they stole this
but i know that they stole this um so
let's let's watch gabe's version
the original version of the u-haul
video
at u-haul we're here to provide you help
uncertainty in an uncertain time we will
continue to meet your transportation and
protest needs u-haul also allows you to
reserve trucks from your burner cell
phone your identity and safety are our
highest priority and to ensure the woke
mob doesn't dox you we meticulously
sanitize our rental equipment to remove
any of your dna after usage for 75 years
we put america first so when you need us
to transport you to and from your next
white nationalist march we'll be here
for you and starting today we are
changing our name to you aisle
oh boy the underwear on the face is just
oh yeah i mean this is what it is i mean
it's the same i've used that outfit
before when i made the one when they uh
when they were at the lincoln memorial
and they all got ditched which is from
which is the night video that was there
when they were loading into the u-haul
but um
yeah that was uh i still had it because
i i wrote this
months ago after it happened and never
got around to filming it well i know
because because you actually because you
actually we talked about some of it now
it was a different video right right it
was it had a little different angle but
we talked about it and i think you had
even went down to uh did you go at the
time
i was going to go at the time and then i
actually ended up doing this on sunday
one day
yeah when i got back from from being out
of town on sunday i went and i went to
go film it
meanwhile the other thing too is i live
or where where uh it is off the street
where the u-haul is it's not a busy
street so i had people passing by and i
was like constantly taking off the hat
and putting the hat back on it kind of
take out the hat because i was like i
don't want people to think that i'm
legitimately a part of this [ __ ]
white nationalist group like i don't
want people to think i'm a [ __ ] nazi
so i had to take the hat off and take it
out i mean you know it's all a joke i'm
wearing underwear and i've got like the
metal
the metal cover for a pot or a pan
uh but still you know people see
something on the corner of the rhine
they see a logo that they think i'm
gonna
i'm gonna be the the the actual bad the
bad person here when i'm not i got you
well
it's i like the underwear on the face
because you did another video with the
underwear on the face
um and in the the pot shield you know uh
we have it looks like we're gonna have
some breaking news
baby i think i know what this is i'm
excited well i don't i don't know
exactly what we're gonna see here but
lincoln watchman has a um
a tweet here about uh breaking news
imminent i know uh they've been teasing
uh you have you heard of this uh fire
bobert it's kind of the same group that
took down madison cawthorne with the uh
cousin humping video
you remember that you were yeah yeah the
butt mohawk right yeah yeah the ask
watch ask watch ask watch um i don't
know if we're gonna get an ask watch
video from bobert but i'm excited if we
do um lincoln watchman says uh major
breaking news imminent after time
staking and thorough research fire
billboard has uncovered yet another
example of lauren boward's hypocrisy
she claims to be staunchly against
abortion but her past reveals something
fear it's different
holy [ __ ]
hypocrisy abortion
christian conservatives will be it will
be fury i'm sure they'll be furious yeah
okay oh boy i i doubt i doubt they'll be
furious about uh i think christian yeah
christian conservatives would be like no
yeah she's just like us yup
we absolutely would have abortion to be
staunchly against it for sure i mean
we're staunch against other people
having abortions not ourselves why would
we staunchly against ourselves having
abortions are using birth control or
trying to take methods to not get
pregnant and we believe in that ability
for us yeah but not them right that's
the you know it is funny that these uh
people are against pronouns but it's
always the us and them with them oh yeah
i mean you know it's very much not
really yeah exactly it's like all for me
not for thee you know so it looks like i
don't know i'm kind of reading between
the lines here and i don't know if we're
gonna have i don't know what's gonna if
one didn't when did that tweet come out
it was 11 48. yeah so this is just
happening in the last 10 minutes oh yeah
i'm not sure exactly
when this is going to drop but um
again it looks like it looks like the
news
it says staunchly against abortion but
her past reveals something different
i don't know if that means that she's
been for abortion or
supported someone in one i don't you
know maybe i don't know maybe herself
it's hard to say but um it looks like
major
breaking news is gonna drop so pay
attention to uh lincoln watchman here or
uh the account fire bobert we've we've
had him on the show
it is really um
it's really something else you know all
these people take their positions and
they try to behind mighty and be like
you know i'm a christian and i'm a
conservative and i have these values
and then you find out
that you know behind closed doors they
were doing some you know that that goes
against
what uh they're they're complaining
about right and uh you know whether it's
madison cawthorn
face humping his cousin
or
watch face lumping
or lauren bober potentially having an
abortion you know
uh i i like how you said that
potentially like she's i don't want to
do her she has i mean who knows you know
i mean maybe she had one maybe you know
i think that's another part of the griff
that a lot of people if if i was if i
was able to um really sit down and
interview donald trump that's one of the
first questions i'd ask him is how many
abortions have you paid yeah like that's
one of the first questions i'd ask him
is how many abortions have you paid for
like how many oh whoa whoa paid for i
think zero
oh well that well i mean he no
trump 100 has never paid for someone
else's abortion he has always amazed
that person pay for the abortion he
thinks so or oh 100
100 percent he can't have his name on
anything there can't be a paper trail so
either he told someone to pay for it or
he made that person
yeah that was pregnant pay for the
abortion themselves it's possible you
know
speaking of paying people stuff when
you're talking about sex and paying
people and trump stormy daniels got 160
grand 130. 130 grand for one it had to
have been less than a minute it was a
couple of pumps
and kimberly giveaway got sixty thousand
dollars for two and a half minutes that
seems out of whack to me i think
kimberly guilfoy should be pissed off at
this point really she should be [ __ ]
upset wait wait wait can you go back
hold on go back
to what go back to the account because
kailyn
is saying two abortions two what oh so
so they've released it maybe they
released it uh let's go down and see
um
unless she's seen something we don't see
but i haven't checked the account again
yeah i'm not i'm not seeing it here um
[Music]
it seems as if we're just um
just we're still waiting we're still
waiting maybe
um
that's that's what i'm i'm getting from
fire beau bert maybe lincoln or was or
caitlin were you talking about trump
oh trump maybe maybe she was talking
about trump okay it's possible or who
knows
i would put look listen i would put way
way more bet that it's way more than two
for trump like oh yeah yeah but he's
funny
100 absolutely that he's facilitated and
that was again if i had to interview him
that would be one of the first questions
i asked him is how many have you paid
for it like that's a thing i really want
to know i gave a [ __ ] about anything
else i don't think he actually has any
beliefs you know we've said this before
that he has no core beliefs
it's not a thing it's not a thing that
he has principle it but it would be nice
to know
oh yeah i mean i'm sure he makes
everyone sign an nda and then he goes
see ya
well yeah and that's it
well yeah yeah and speaking of people
who have no beliefs and no principle
dinesh d'souza this is this is a
fantastic tweet um they say how it
started and how it's going this is a
tweet about bill barr
from 418 19 is when it's from um
is what we have here i'm going to take
the banner off here let's show you it's
4 18 19 here
and dinesh decision says when the media
left
goes berserk
republicans typically panic
i love the way barr and he's referring
to bill barr stays cool and methodically
hits back with facts
and logic
that's the way to deal with these
dishonest creeps keep calm and whack
them again
mueller date now of course dinesh
d'souza is talking about how
uh bob uh bill barr covered up bob
mueller's report about russia and the
collusion right he redacted it and
dinesh decision loves that he lied about
it now look what dinesh disease has said
about bill barr
yesterday
um because he said that 2000 mules was a
bunch of horse [ __ ] and he's kind of
laughing about it yeah i mean
as soon as he was brought up he was like
this is [ __ ] dumb [ __ ] dumb it's
stupid you shouldn't watch this pile of
[ __ ] we've actually thought about
actually streaming it to give people a
chance to hear it we just want to give
commentary over it so we can say that's
a bunch of [ __ ] that's a bunch of
[ __ ] as it's playing so that way
someone can't just replay it and say oh
look they're supporting it where we're
actually trying to [ __ ] debunk some
of it right we've thought about i mean
the best part of the 2000 mules is like
we solved uh
we solved a murder case based on gps
data from cell phones it's like no you
no you didn't
so that that's one of the claims they
make that's one of the claims and
everyone's like what the other claim
they make is that oh ballots were in
boxes and shipped on trucks and billbar
yesterday was like yeah of course they
were how the [ __ ] do you think they get
from a polling location to the place
where they're counted they put them in
[ __ ] boxes and they i thought i
thought they got teleported tony yeah
right beat me up scotty i i think that
might be technology that dinesh d'souza
is working on i don't know but here's
what he said yesterday in a tweet this
little [ __ ] [ __ ] this whiny little
[ __ ] [ __ ] because he's being exposed
as a [ __ ] liar and a propagandist
uh he says bill barr is a stereo
stereotypical small town sheriff
overweight and largely mobile first
thing i want to point out is i thought
these people were for the police weren't
they back to blue yeah they were back to
blue till january 6th well now he's
saying a small town sheriff is bad
right
wasn't trump just a [ __ ] couple weeks
ago calling for sheriffs to arrest joe
biden and [ __ ]
at mar-a-lago and here dinesh d'souza is
saying sheriffs are dumb and stupid and
overweight and largely immobile whose
rank and competence results in the the
whole town being robbed
under his nose
okay
um and i i really
again the back to blue thing really kind
of
dis yeah i mean like it's you know
much like the lauren bobert situation
republicans are hypocrites
and
they you know they'll say one thing and
do the complete opposite and act high
and mighty and self-righteous and say
look at these guys look at what they're
doing when in reality they're the ones
that are doing that same thing and are
projecting it on to another group of
people whether it be pedophilia sex
trafficking abortions uh uh taking away
voting rights uh you know being [ __ ]
racist or fascist like name you name it
there's a list of things where it's like
check off the list of what it takes to
be a republican and the number one thing
on there is be hypocrite and then
underneath the sub bullet points or all
the different talking points of things
you need to be like if you've done one
of these or currently do one of these
but talk against doing these things
then you're perfect right well you know
this last part is even better than the
than the going against back the blue
because he he continues his little
whiny little [ __ ] rant here he says
then
asked to explain how it happened
fatso breaks into laughter and insists
the robbery itself is [ __ ] i love
the fatso comment this is hilarious
because his orange mussolini jesus the
guy that he's making this whole movie
about to gas light to gaslight not just
his supporters but donald trump
supporters into believing [ __ ] about
the [ __ ] election was stolen so they
can create some kind of quote-unquote
evidence video evidence which there is
video of them moving boxes because
that's how it works yeah they're they're
like what did they why did they come
into the building with the ballots yeah
because they wanted to count the balance
right it's real well they didn't want to
count the ballots that were bidens and
that's the point here but i love how he
calls bill barfat so have you ever seen
pictures of bill barr and donald trump
standing next to each other yeah yeah
yeah have you ever seen it yeah how
would you define those two standing next
to each other i mean
what would you would there be a good
word to define those two
no no i'm not gonna hear anything i'm
not gonna body shame but i will i
[ __ ] will i will
what i like about this is the fact that
and you'll see this across the board if
you go on twitter facebook tick tock
whatever
uh you'll see people
from the right come into your comments
and say this is a false claim that
you're making and then you say well
you're talking about whatever factor
yeah yeah it could be whatever like i
get it a lot when i was you know when
doing sketches like the trump fun one
that was another one where we were like
this is totally fake and i'm like dude
it's literally on the website just read
the legal clause that you you us uh you
agree to
but with these people they'll say like
oh you know what uh that's fake and i
don't believe you and you need to give
me facts okay fine here are some
articles oh well i won't trust this site
because it's xyz and it's not the
washington times and it's not uh you
know fox news or something
and if it doesn't go with what they
agree with and they say fake news right
and is if they cannot prove what their
talking point actually is right they've
talked themselves into a circle just
themselves and disproven their own point
then they immediately
result to name calling personal attacks
right fatso trump loves giving people
nicknames right but this is a page out
of trump's book which is a page out of
just the maga book which is if i can't
win the argument because i don't
actually have
uh actual substance and evidence to
prove my point then i'm just gonna call
you a fatso i'm gonna call you an idiot
i'm gonna attack you as a person
and then say
i'm the better person i'm the actual
correct person in this argument this
debate that we're having you know what
it works really well you know what works
really well if you do both you just have
the facts and then call them out on
their [ __ ] oh yeah you're yeah
you're you're a chubby idiot i mean i'm
i'm all for that everyone knows that i'm
for coming at them you know punch for
punch here right
the best news about being pro-democracy
is you can be for the facts because you
you don't have to be scared of democracy
i mean you have to work hard for it it's
hard it's difficult this [ __ ] is
difficult right but they don't want to
work hard for it that's why dinesh
d'souza does this [ __ ] because he wants
it to be easy steve bannon wants to be
easy they want to wave a magic wand and
execute liberals right so that way they
don't have to deal with people who don't
agree with their opinion right well in a
democracy you have to do that you have
to deal with people who do not have your
opinion like that is the thing that you
have to do but that's the whole point of
how it works and why it's difficult to
compromise on some of these things
that's why that's why someone um who
came on our our thursday coverage uh
everyone knows lee mcgowan as politics
girl she put out a video and it was
called dear trump supporters and it's
it's fantastic and she's actually trying
to give a call to him like hey it's okay
it's not really your fault
your your prior beliefs your your
you know the stuff that you want to
believe they're using that against you
and it's not necessarily your fault it's
just your predisposition to believe
these things they know that and so
they're using that against you in their
propaganda and i wanna i wanna show that
here real quick um because i think it's
it's great to talk about this hearing
and what it means against like dinesh
d'souza pumping out misinformation and
[ __ ] lying to you about how ballots
are moved i mean let's not forget
dinosaur sugar is a felon okay right he
is a felon he is a fraud well not not
only is he and not only is he a felon
he's a felon because of election fraud
that is the key thing here is that the
guy you're listening to
about elections and how ballots work and
all this [ __ ] went to [ __ ] federal
prison because he committed felonies
because of elections and [ __ ]
campaign finance and donations right
let's get that clear and then trump
obvious and then trump came in and was
like i'll save you and right you know
pardon him right exactly which i wonder
if this movie is a payback for that
pardon i don't know i'm just surprising
you let's listen to
let's listen to lee
for her call to trumpers
and and trump supporters
to know hey it's okay you've been lied
to we're all right with it too we know
you've been lied to hi so if you're a
trump supporter and you're watching the
1-6 hearings or seeing clips from them
and you're feeling confused or angry or
betrayed that's understandable if you
believed trump's lies about the election
being stolen that's not your fault the
president of the united states lied to
you he lied to you for his own benefit
he lied to you to stay in power he lied
to you to grift money more than 250
million dollars worth of money that he
didn't use for an election defense fund
like he told you but he transferred into
another account so he could do what he
wanted with it he lied to you because
the presidency was profitable and he
didn't want to let it go he was legally
untouchable his hotels were thriving and
he had the respect and power he thought
he deserved the country spent 150
million dollars for him to visit his own
properties his daughter made 640 million
dollars on her trademarks and businesses
while working at the white house his
son-in-law made two billion dollars from
the people who blew up the twin towers
and the republican national committee
paid the rest of his children and their
spouses and girlfriends just to exist it
was a racket but as long as he was still
perceived as a winner he could still ask
you for money everyone in his circle
knew he was lying to you but they let
him do it because it served them it
served their desire for power their
agenda and their book sales it served
the election laws they changed in the
name of his lies it served their desire
for one party rule
he lied to you they all lied to you and
that's not your fault you're supposed to
be able to believe the president of the
united states you're supposed to be able
to believe your news channel you're
supposed to be able to believe the
lawyers that speak with authority on
television but they lied and they will
keep lying because they think you won't
check
they think you won't change the channel
or watch the hearings or use your own
mind to figure it out
they conju and they think they can keep
calming you but this isn't something you
should feel bad about it's something
they should feel bad about but they
won't because they don't care
the question is
do you
so we see the schedule here of course
it's changed a bit since she released
this video because this morning with
this morning's news again tomorrow um we
are not going to have live coverage of
the hearing because it's been postponed
we will thursday it seems like they're
going to go ahead with the
the meeting on thursday and i don't know
i i haven't confirmed this yet um i
don't know if they're moving the doj
witnesses to thursday and then moving
forward or they're going to
do the doj witnesses on a different day
have we figured that out yet no i i
don't know it's hard to tell that
because they haven't really announced
much other than it's postponed right
it's just well they said they just from
what i understand they just needed more
time so i don't know exactly
what that means and well
it could mean that there's witnesses
that have decided that someone went into
labor and they're not going to appear so
then they need to get their clips
together i don't know i'm just saying
that that might be
that could very well be uh lincoln
watchman actually sent me a reply here
to um
um
the tweet that i sent out um and it
looks like
uh they said lincoln watchman says
fantastic we should have a press release
and story ready to go any minute
yeah let's see here only let me pull
this up so everyone can see
lincoln watchman is confirming here
let's see
here's lincoln watchman says fantastic
should have a press release and story
ready to go any minute
any minute so this billboard story
whatever this bobert story that was like
almost 15 minutes ago all right so we're
coming up
on something if you would keep an eye on
that for me i'm going to go to i got
some more video i want to show you um of
some boneheads and bonnet boy is going
to be it's going to be a great week for
boneheads this week
the month of june really
really doing it for us right uh it's
it's it's lush with boneheads i mean um
we have hershel walker dinesh d'souza
already today um
clear clear
obvious possible uh candidates for bone
end of the week but here oh my god of
course we have a uh not a newcomer to
the bone end of the week she is a
constant a constant contestant on
bonehead and this is marjorie taylor
green now uh you know this is really
[ __ ] stupid
that that she would even say this [ __ ]
but these people are dumb and they say
stupid [ __ ] like this the thing that
really pisses me off about this is that
she is an elected official saying this
stupid [ __ ] right like this is the whole
reason why it's relevant to [ __ ] play
her saying anything in the first place
is because her constituents are still
voting this nonsense in like you are
still voting for this garbage when this
woman is spreading around not just lies
but i mean just laughable type stuff
when she says here i think she calls it
earth warming is good for growing food i
think she says but she's suggesting that
growing seasons are longer or something
and this is obviously a person
is she talking about like climate change
i'm not [ __ ] you she says the earth
warming is good for growing seasons that
we're growing more food which this is
really [ __ ] boneheaded because anyone
who grows anything rather flower or food
knows that you rely on the climate where
you're growing the food yeah to be
consistent like you want it to be
consistent but let's listen to the
[ __ ]
margaery hoof foot green here this is
this is hard to listen to but it's only
39 seconds
we've already warmed one degree celsius
and do you know what's happened since
then
here let me tell you we have had more
food grown i love it i love it when she
says
here let me tell you here let me let me
let me break down
the facts that have nothing to do with
what i'm talking about like she's
pulling facts
like oh we grew more food yeah the
reason why is because we had more
subsidies that were paying farmers
through the farm bill through welfare or
welfare to grow more food you dummy
one one sec she said it it bumped up one
degree celsius
right
that's what that's what she well here
i'll back it up we'll replay it
we've already warmed one degree celsius
and do you know what's happening the
whole planet
it sounds like she's bragging about it
doesn't it i don't mean
people here's the thing like i
wonder one degree celsius is like what
32 33 degrees fahrenheit
isn't
33.8 degrees fahrenheit is one degree
celsius
so what she's
i want to know one what region of the
world
into
33 degree 33.8 degrees fahrenheit
what the [ __ ] that's like going from you
know like it's like oh hey it's uh it's
springs uh spring fall uh
spring fall weather right which is like
65.
33 degrees
that's 98 degrees not nicolas shay 98
degrees that is 98 degrees
hot oh what a great what a what a great
new
um group that you've created one degree
celsius um you know maybe like is that a
boy i mean unless i'm doing the math
wrong here and i forget how to convert
in terms of uh
okay wait hold on someone says 1 degree
celsius is 2.2 degrees fahrenheit
okay am i wrong i could be wrong i don't
know let's let's listen to what she says
about food though this is hilarious
here let me tell you we have had more
food grown since then which feeds people
we are able to producing fossil fuels
keeps people's houses warm in the winter
okay so
so she's saying she's saying that that
that the warming of the earth as she's
claiming number one grows more food okay
she's also claiming that the warming of
the earth provides more fossil fuels i'm
not sure how what where she i don't know
what that even means
like does she mean that just because
the warmer weather they can pump oil out
of the ground longer she knows that they
pump oil
in arctic temperatures right i i uh
i can't even i can't i don't even know
man i'm so confused oh it gets better it
gets better it it gets dumber man it
just gets dumber and dumber and dumber
even in 39 seconds right i mean this
video is 39 seconds long we're halfway
through and we already got past we're
not even done yet
not even oh my god no not even done here
we go that saves people's lives people
die in the car right
this this earth warming and and carbon
is is actually healthy for us it is it's
able it helps us to feed people it helps
keep people alive it helps there's the
earth is more green than it was um years
and years ago and that's because of the
earth warming that's because of carbon
because
because of earth warming and carbon gabe
yeah you got your you got your mic off
there i don't know
sorry there was there was a helicopter
okay oh i got you oh okay hold on hold
on
she's saying that oh she's saying like
she's saying a lot of dumb [ __ ] the
warmer temperature is good it is better
for the world that's what she's saying i
live in california okay i've been living
through a job for some time we've you
know come back a little bit but we're
still in a drought right now
that is great if you don't gabe you
don't need water you don't need water so
confused you do not need water for life
and this logic
like i mean if you're really trying to
break down this person and the word
logic you were on the wrong you were on
the wrong path here literally she is
just saying stuff because someone wants
to hear this
yeah
okay all right so dark pepsi says so the
one degree celsius is 1.8 degree
fahrenheit in global temperature
increase and exactly
that has
world wide
impacts
on areas whether it's in california or
it's in africa or it's an asian whatever
it might be right like you look at this
and to just excuse like it's one degree
difference it's fine
well that same type of logic is like
well the the water in the ocean or in in
around the world
because of melted polar caps only rose
half an inch like that's not a big deal
like that half an inch has [ __ ] huge
impacts well the other thing that i had
on what she's saying because what she's
saying here is that hot because here's
her logic right here's her dumb [ __ ]
stupid
three three-toed hoof foot logic here oh
no we found her she has four she has
four toes oh she has four turns okay
her hoof foot yeah trailer park logic
here here's what it is
is that
if it's warmer outside for longer you
must be able to grow more food that's
that's what she's saying yeah right and
if that's the case if that's the case
then it must be a good thing but that is
not how [ __ ] growth
that is not how food growth works in a
lot of regions in a lot of regions you
actually have to have certain periods of
frost to grow certain crops
this is and and really certain regions
of like alaska they're having trouble
because they don't have the freeze right
they do not have the freeze in their
region because their region relies on
that consistent freeze of the climate
she is such a [ __ ] bonehead that it's
not even funny but here's the scary part
it's not that people are listening to
her i mean people have listened to alex
jones about chemtrails and lizard people
and all kinds of weird ass [ __ ] for
years
and believed everything that
[ __ ] says
what is really scary here is that she is
a congress person alex jones has never
been an elected member of congress can
you [ __ ] imagine if alex jones was
elected to congress you don't have to
imagine because all you have to do is
look at marjory taylor green and
understand that that kind of crazy that
kind of [ __ ] that kind of nonsense
is elected to our [ __ ] house of
representatives
this is as if alex jones was elected to
our [ __ ] congress that's what it's
like that's how [ __ ] that's why this
is right it's uh oh my god man i like
i don't even know how to
i don't even know how to to handle this
um
the stupidity
the i mean we saw a clip last week where
she was talking to matt gates and matt
gates was like using some big words for
her
and uh and she's like
right yeah yeah yeah and she like goes
off and does her like pondering look or
whatever and it's like
okay look we all know you're an idiot
and you're clearly having a difficulty
following along with the conversation
right now but this is just another
example where you know she's pulling
[ __ ] out of her ass in terms of what
she's talking about like oh one degree
celsius no big deal no big deal it
totally yeah it doesn't sound that it
doesn't sound i mean yeah we want it to
be warmer gabe see they get that's the
other thing that they use like they use
weather and climate as if it's the same
thing weather and climate are not the
same [ __ ] thing speaking of
[ __ ] boneheads and propagandists
here's the king of nazi propagandist
himself with his [ __ ] foot soldier
here um on i like that jesus on her
shoulder yeah right
traitor tv here
as i call it um he is freaking the [ __ ]
out man he is freaking out listen to
this guy we are dedicated to show that
biden stole this we have to do this
for people that came before us we're not
guardians and graves all of you clowns
we are not stopping until we get all the
audits done and show the american people
stolen look at
so he's still talking about audits he's
still talking about getting honest done
which gabe any audit that they've
actually done has gone the opposite
direction of what they were right it
ends up showing they're like oh [ __ ]
bind got more votes right well because
that's generally and that's what
ginsburg was trying to get at yesterday
the republican election attorney he's
like look when you have margins that are
over the hundreds
when you do recounts it generally sways
in the way of the person who's already
winning that's why
generally speaking when you get into the
thousands of votes not percentage-wise
but in the number of votes
you really do not want to do a recount
if you're a losing candidate because
you're gonna lose by more
and that is what's happened in these
recounts time and time again in georgia
and arizona now michigan other places
where they force these recounts is joe
biden has won by more and the reason why
is because the margin higher it is more
likely when you have a higher
vote count for one candidate than the
other it is very probable that when you
recount there's going to be more votes
maybe a few maybe a dozen maybe a couple
hundred but there's gonna be more votes
in the way of the winner it's just
probability it's [ __ ] math it's not
hard to understand this stuff
but he's still talking about [ __ ]
audits here as if these audits are gonna
reveal something even their [ __ ]
stupid movie 2 000 meals which was
supposed to be well
let's let's rewind the clock back to
mike lindell's um little cyber symposium
i'm still waiting for him to uh to show
up to the supreme court with a 9-0
decision but well you know this maybe
this september 29 or 89th we'll get
something
i don't know but steve bannon was the
was the [ __ ] push behind that
symposium and then the then the cyber
ninjas and on and on it goes with these
audits and this [ __ ] and they try to
spin this nonsense with this 2000 mules
which is absolute [ __ ] it's just
footage that they put scary narrative
over it to make people who want to
believe it believe it so that way you
think oh my god there was ballots moved
in boxes which is what happens it
happened when trump won in 2016 just
like when he lost in 2020. and here
steve bannon is freaking the [ __ ] out
that trump isn't gonna be president
listen to the end
look at the catastrophic consequences of
your theft you think we're going to let
you get away with the answer is wait for
it no
okay it is not going to happen you've
tried to destroy this country and we're
not going to allow
i mean he's totally freaking out here he
knows he's going to get federally
indicted i mean well i mean he's also
the one who just recently filed a
lawsuit against the january 6 committee
or a subpoena against them in an attempt
to uh fight their
um
their uh charge of contempt
from from last year because he's his is
coming up this summer isn't it well i
mean he's gonna he's gonna get a tick
tock here of of his trial on the
contempt charges just like everyone else
but i think it's going to go much deeper
with steve bannon in january 6 than just
a contempt charge from congress i think
that's why he took the contempt charge i
think that's why navarro took it i think
that's why meadows took it clark took it
is because the contempt charge really
the thing about the contempt charge
is that they want
they would much rather
be framed up as the contempt charge
where they might get a fine and they
might get a couple months as opposed to
seditious conspiracy
um to commit sedition right i mean
that's that's where the big charges come
from or the big t which is treason which
is going to be hard to prove but if they
can prove this as an act of war which
they're marching towards that with the
proud boys and oath keepers evidence
they might and you know the thing the
telling thing about this clip and let me
let me pull it back up here the telling
thing about this clip why he knows he's
going to be indicted um listen to who he
whose name he couples with garland
and graves all of you garland and graves
do you know who graves is gabe
no graves is a united states attorney in
the uh the acting attorney in the
district of dc okay so he is the one who
is actually going to bring charges or
bring recommendations to merrick garland
that's one thing that people get really
[ __ ] confused about merrick garland
merrick garland is the attorney general
of the united states he's not the u.s
attorney in the district of columbia now
he is that person's boss right so he is
over that person so more than likely if
there is uh charges or
sealed indictments that they want to
bring through grand juries
they're going to go to merritt garland
with those recommendations and that's
why you've already seen merrick garland
say look if anyone brings me a
reasonable recommendation i'm probably
going to sign off on that son of a [ __ ]
yeah so we're waiting for the united
states attorney in the dc district to
sign off or make these recommendations
through their grand juries that's why
steve bannon is calling him out because
graves is the one who's going to bring
the evidence to the grand jury about
january 6. he's the one that's going to
seal indictments for bannon roger stone
trump and the likes if they had anything
to do eastman with the seditious
conspiracy to overthrow our government
and our vote
so that's why steve bannon throws in
that name graves so i want everyone to
understand that that even steve bannon
understands that merrick garland is not
the decider here when it comes to what
charges are going to be brought and who
is going to present the evidence to the
grand jury its graves and that's super
important um
do we still have we looked at um is this
bobert stuff dropped yet
i haven't seen an update let me go back
okay well let's take a quick break and
then we'll be right back everyone stick
around
we'll be right back right after this
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny
we know what you would do you'd reach
out and give that true american a hand
now here's your chance for only 50
dollars a day you can help us help those
true americans recover from biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those trump supporters and this is that
moment
send your donation via venmo to the real
president donald j trump
it's only fifty dollars a day recurring
and it means you'll get these trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime
please donate now because those trump
supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
[ __ ] em
[ __ ] em [ __ ] up welcome
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for sticking around through the
break
[Music]
smashing the
2 000 mules
from yesterday's broadcast of the
january 6th select earrings the public
hearings uh gabe when he when he did
this um i tweeted out that he took
massive dumps all over 2000 mules a big
massive dumps to be specific yeah but
here he absolutely destroys this idea
that it is even [ __ ] relevant let's
listen
i sat there flipping through the report
and looking through it and
to be frank it looked very amateurish to
me didn't have the credentials of the
people involved but i didn't see any
real
qualifications and the statements were
made very uh
uh conclusory like this these machines
were designed to you know engage in
fraud or something for that effect but i
didn't see any supporting
information for it
and i was
somewhat demoralized because i thought
boy if he really believes this stuff he
has you know
lost contact with with uh
he's become detached from reality now
bill barr is here is talking about
donald trump
and you know everyone wants to hail him
as a [ __ ] hero here but this guy is
saying this behind closed doors under
oath okay yeah
and he has to say it under oath and he
has to tell the truth here and the
reason why is because this is in his
notes right these government officials
take notes and people take notes with
them when they're in rooms that's the
story where donald trump was eating
[ __ ] notes from a meeting
because he didn't want those notes to be
entered into um the government archive
as a and it
may become evidence against him one day
uh bill barry if you recall from the
first hearing
refers to three meetings that he can
recall is what he says because he looked
at his notes and those are the three
meetings now
that's what bill barr is doing here is
he's only telling you what is in his
notes that the committee can prove based
on the records that they gained from him
that they subpoenaed so he's telling
them the [ __ ] just his synopsis here
of what those notes would show in the
first place and he's giving his first
hand account on film
but listen to the part about the 2000
mules here at the end
if he really believes this stuff
on the other hand you know when i went
into this and
would
you know tell them how crazy some of
these allegations were there was never
there was never an indication of
interest in what the actual facts were
in my opinion then and my opinion now
is that
the election was not stolen by fraud
and
i haven't seen anything since the
election that changes my mind on that
including the 2000 mules movie
[Laughter]
and he lashed it off like it's a joke
because it is a [ __ ] joke right like
even even ben shapiro it's like that
that's not even close to be that's all
[ __ ]
when you can't convince ben shapiro of a
piece of propaganda you are [ __ ]
failing miserably
miserably flailing if you if you can't
convince ben shapiro of a piece of
propaganda
i mean it really is sad about this 2000
mules thing and i really think we should
still stream it and and and do
commentary oh yeah yeah we should
definitely i mean you know i've got it
i've got it ready to go right yeah we do
it yeah we lifted it and we're not going
to pay for it either dinesh d'souza
come at us bro
come at us i'm just saying [ __ ] i
committed
renter fraud i don't know like renter
fraud wait i'm just trying to think like
what the equivalent you know like you
know i i didn't pay for it i got it well
i mean you know what we do we just we
just don't monetize that video and you
can't you can't say that we're trying to
make money off of it you know right
right i mean they can try to get it
pulled down because of copyright or
whatever but you know if if we are going
off fair use laws and we commentate over
the whole thing we're creating a brand
new piece of content totally my eyes
totally new relevant piece of content
content to tell them how much of a piece
of [ __ ] that really is um have we seen
the bobert i i'm so excited about this
book i haven't seen it i haven't seen
anything it hasn't dropped yet what the
hell is going on over there we need to
get this
news to drop
they're talking about abortions in this
thing
and i want to know i want to know who
got the abortions i want to know what
she is still you know as a 49 minutes
ago it's still the one from the lincoln
watchman god damn it well i i maybe
we'll maybe we'll get it live on the air
here i'm hoping we got 22 minutes
speaking of being live on the air gabe
we go live every single weekday monday
through friday noon eastern 11 central
for two full hours every two hours
monday through friday
on youtube twitter twitch so don't
forget to go follow us on youtube
the tony michael's podcast just search
it if you're there right now subscribe
give us a thumbs up a like
also download the podcast every single
weekday monday through friday all two
hours
on apple spotify google are your
favorite directory
and then we put up a favorite like a
best of on saturday that you can
download
last saturday we put up um just a
commentary
from thursday's episode and then
yesterday because we were doing coverage
i took the commentary from yesterday's
episode and put it up on the directories
as well so that that is officially
episode
uh 60. today is 61 right i don't know i
lose track it is
61. oh yeah yeah 161. yep today is 161.
so yesterday our commentary coverage
ended up being 160 because we were
broadcasting during our live coverage so
we shot the live coverage over on our
youtube once we got to that time so you
guys seen us on our channel as soon as
you could um at that regular time so
come just participate in the super chat
if you'd like some people were talking
about my hat today
in the chat you can go to
thetonymichaels.com somebody said they
would give you a thousand dollars for a
signed hat are you [ __ ] [ __ ] me a
thousand dollars somebody i see when i
first when i came in i'll fart in the
son of a [ __ ] when i came into the chat
somebody said i'll try to find it but
somebody was like oh yeah i'll give you
a thousand bucks tony for a sign i'll
find one i'll say you know you know the
girl that sells their farts in a jar i
think i'm hey i might start doing that
me just put a [ __ ] sticker on it and
start farting in jars and selling it i
don't know i i'd do that would you sell
your farts in a jar i mean why not you
know
maybe i should put that on the merch
store if i can make money
you know might as well grift everyone
else is doing it but you know if people
are into that then [ __ ] it why would
someone pay for someone's farts in a jar
i don't know you know
i'm not here to kink shame but that's
what people are into that's why no i'm i
i'm just wondering what the kink is
that's what i'm saying
the odor i don't know
is it because it's a particular type of
fart like you know you know there's
different types of health i mean there's
different batches that you could brew up
you know taco tuesday gabe and you know
i'm so excited type you can get a
certain type of taco fart like there's a
cheeseburger fart there's a taco fart
right yeah i mean there's all sorts
there's there's you know the you've been
drinking all day fart there's the
farts yeah
whatever popcorn farts you ever had
popcorn parts right you're real dry
yeah
oh i've been been there done that you
know
um how did we get on farts again i'm not
sure oh we were talking about selling
farts you know selling uh selling the
hat i'm trying to find this comment oh
okay yeah we're gonna find it i'm gonna
find it but um here here's what i'll
tell you about taco tuesday um i'm i
think i think i'm gonna make my regular
tacos for time oh okay but i know i know
gabe you like to
you're kind of a connoisseur so you like
that it has some you know
some variety so what kind of tacos are
you planning on tonight if are you
planning on tacos tonight
uh let's see it's tuesday night yeah i
do have stuff in the fridge i need to
make
okay veggies veggies so we have veggies
we need to make maybe veggie tacos could
be veggie tacos i need to go get some
tortillas oh
but i could make veggie
tacos i'm just saying
tuesday i put it i put it on the uh i
put it on
the trending thing so i wanted to make
sure i thought i mean it's never not
trending that's the thing it could be
any day and it's taco day why i talk to
you about taco tuesday on tuesday i like
to talk right now
i mean i i appreciate it you know if i'm
not gonna get tacos i'd love to talk
about them even when i'm cooking my
tacos sometimes i send pictures to gabe
of my tacos and he's like that's not
that's not talking
[Laughter]
he does not believe that the tacos that
i make look i've had the tacos you've
had you know i'm from the midwest i've
had those before what what is that what
does that mean what does that mean
exactly it means that uh especially in
the 90s and early 2000s like i feel like
certain areas are are uh and just as a
disclosure you you are well versed in
in in restaurants selling mexican food
yeah yeah yeah
exactly yeah my my dad uh that's what he
does so i'm you know tag along and do
all this stuff in terms of you know
seeing the kids he's a chef he's a chef
yeah you've been in the kitchen you've
worked in the restaurant so you know you
know you know tacos right i know exactly
so
uh for the midwest tacos the like here's
the ground beef with the seasoning and
the hard shell or soft tilt or soft
tacos whatever you want you know you're
putting in your tomatoes maybe your
chopped lettuce some onions possibly
um those are i look at those and i'm
like those are those are fine like
those are tacos those are tacos but
the ones that i want are the ones that
are you know albest store or carnitas or
carnesada or
our audience kind of describes some of
these what this means uh okay so alpha
store is uh very very good um it's uh
have you ever seen
have you ever seen like euros like on a
on a
pit right that's it's a
meat
shape little shavings
glaze and then you're like chopping off
pineapple to go into it and that's
basically it like oh so this is this is
like this is like real [ __ ] this isn't
yeah yeah real real stuff
and cold ass shredded lettuce
i mean you're not really getting any
lettuce on these tacos at all uh you're
getting you know carne sala tacos which
are
steak you know beef
um
you know simple
uh
onions
uh cilantro right salsa boom that's it
that's it basic that and boom that's a
taco because i asked you last week
because i was like okay because this is
a bait in our family is what's a taco
what's a burrito right what's the
difference yeah what is the difference
and i didn't know this i always thought
that burrito was the
the flower soft shell
and the taco was the
the corn shell right that was the
difference but it's but apparently by
your by your definition and it's not it
is the size
of the tortilla
that makes well yeah i mean like if
you've got a if you've got a you know a
small little taco tortilla which is you
know probably like four or five inches
of you know round right but if then
you've got a burrito right which is
another tortilla it's a flour tortilla
that's much larger which might be like
11 inches that's what makes it a burrito
right right and then you you know but in
that one you know you've got i mean
again you can make tacos with any of the
ingredients you put in a burrito but yes
it is very much the way in which you
prepare it and wrap it that makes it the
burrito and then of course you deep fry
it and you put sauce on it becomes
totally different things you know right
so that's the beauty so that's that's
the thing that i did not know
because technically gabe and you're
going to be very disappointed here on
taco tuesdays because i buy the bigger
um flour tortillas yeah i technically am
having burrito tuesday yeah you're just
having like open burritos right yeah
yeah right as opposed to because that's
what my family likes they like the
really big flower tortillas to put tacos
with him i mean sometimes like hey look
i you know sometimes snack on just
regular huge tortillas or another good
snack another little cheap uh snack that
i grew up on was you have a tortilla it
could be flour but typically it was corn
you know maybe you want to put a little
lime like sprinkle of lime juice in from
a lime and then you uh
put a little salt in
and then
roll it up and it's tight and a little
snack right there and that's well now
now that our audience is completely
starving because dave was describing
tacos here's that here's that message
christopher martin says tony i'll give
you one thousand dollars for that hat
signed oh baby i'll sign it like i said
i'll fart in it whatever you want i'll
send you this hat for a thousand bucks
i'll send it to you you just you just go
to uh
go to twitter at i am
uh well i am gabe sanchez at the
attorney michaels and the tony michael's
podcast follow one of us dm one of us
i'll get you a hat if you want a hat
yeah my friend with this so anyway it's
time
and i've been yeah for a thousand bucks
i would take that thousand bucks
but you would have it but i would take
the thousand bucks and i would just
you know buy us some tacos for lunch oh
yeah well i think gabe is telling me he
wants me to buy him some tacos
let's go to the tweeze sweets and drink
drinks here diet speaking of food diet
pepsi is trending and it looks like it's
rudy giuliani rudy giuliani says in the
tweet that he refused all alcohol on
election night and that his favorite
drink is diet pepsi after the house
this is not real is it i don't know
he blocked me on twitter so i don't know
if he's actually telling the truth right
now come on
i don't think he has me blocked um here
that looks like a screenshot i don't
want a screenshot i want the actual
[ __ ] tweet here just look him up well
yeah but i want to i'm going to
find it on the i'm gonna i forget why he
i forgot what i said to him that he
blocked me i forgot if i was talking
about his leaking hair or i'm surprised
he hasn't blocked me and the reason why
i i'm surprised by that is
the real reason is because i i i gave
him the handle grandpa farty mcshardy
wait do you remember the whole moment
when he farted on janelle is there
something dropping here wait wait
nope sorry somebody said to go look at
fire bobert and uh
i'm not seeing anything yet sorry sorry
my apologies somebody said
somebody said uh
holy crap guys go look at fire beau bird
i just went to fire bobert i'm not
seeing anything new is it the same is it
the same tweet as earlier i'm refreshing
the page let me see if something new got
dropped no major breaking news imminent
still
still the original one
okay i'm trying to find this diet pepsi
uh tweet here that's why i was hoping
just to just to click on it uh the 11.
they said hold on now they're saying
someone's saying it's there
maybe my
page isn't loading correctly
what is it what is there what is there
there is there
i don't know
and talk about abortions oh no no it's
okay never mind it's on there but it's
on the lincoln watchman 10 minutes ago i
don't see it on fire boborg okay it's so
it's on lincoln watching page okay let's
see if we can grab this uh [ __ ] rudy for
a minute i mean not literally just oh
boy oh boy
this is something else man
wow is this uh
holy [ __ ] folks hang on to your hat um
i'm we're gonna we're gonna pull this up
on the screen here to let everyone oh
man we got 10 minutes and this might be
the full 10 minutes here click on that
link look at that
major breaking news uh fire bobert
uncovers that lauren bobert was an
unlicensed paid escort with
sugardaddymeat.com is that the same
sugar daddy thing that matt gets
i don't
holy [ __ ] senator ted cruz's name and is
in this yeah bobert met
senator ted cruz and aspen through coke
family member
escort client what the [ __ ]
full details
what the hell i'm retweeting this um
again
i don't know
exactly what the evidence here is until
we click on this link but the lincoln
watchman is claiming here that fire
bobert uncovers uh that lauren bobert
was an unlicensed paid escort with
sugardaddymeet.com
and had two abortions i'm not sure if
it's as a result of her work as a paid
escort
um
unlicensed it says is there such thing
as a license licensed payday i don't
know
anyways
besides the point maybe it's state to
state uh but it says bobert met
senator ted cruz in aspen
through coke family member escort client
the full details in this article below
bobert abortion
bobert abortions is probably going to be
trending
um holy actual [ __ ] so what we're what
we're discovering here is it sounds like
lauren bobert who is vehemently against
abortions and she thinks people who have
abortions are murderers
has had two abortions gabe this is not
surprising really honestly i mean it's
not surprising that i mean i just the
ted cruz thing the ted cruz thing is
[ __ ] wild if ted did takers have sex
with her is that what this is saying i
don't no this is crazy
yeah was hired by a wealthy male client
in aspen can you can you read it out
loud to us yeah yeah so according to our
investigation um i can start from the
top sil colorado the american muckrakers
pack inc today announced their team and
volunteers have uncovered that lauren
bobert was an unlicensed paid escort and
paid in and met clients through
sugardaddymeat.com text messages show
she was bankrupt at the time and looking
for side income in quotes and called her
work pay to play so so it's probably
quotes they're quoting text messages or
something yeah yeah exactly they called
her work pay to play she was paid to
escort wealthy men according to our
investigation in 2019 bobert was hired
by a wealthy male client in aspen
colorado who is a koch family member
bobert's rich client subsequently
introduced her to u.s senator ted cruz
and aspen in 2019 after meeting senator
ted cruz bobert was encouraged to
buy him to run for u.s congress
after billboard announced her campaign
for congress in december 2019 senator
ted cruz
donated
126 thousand dollars to the bobert
campaign and helped her raise large sums
of money during trips bobert made to
texas bobert didn't disclose a 75 dollar
donation until cruz's federal election
commission finance contradicted her
finances
had an abortion at the planned
parenthood clinic in glenwood springs
colorado due to her work with a sugar
daddymeet.com client beaubert also had
another abortion at a clinic in grand
junction colorado it is not known
whether the second abortion billboard
had was related to the aspen client or a
different sugar daddy meet.com client or
someone else american
muckrakers obtain this information
through an exhaustive investigation and
a tip from a verified source close to
the matter who has requested anonymity
for a
fear of reprisals
oh boy oh it continues it can oh my god
so we got a second page here yeah so
david b wheeler president of the
american ruckraker's packing said the
following lauren opal beaubert is as big
of a hypocrite as madison cawthorne he
says one thing and doesn't uh he says in
one thing does another she says she is
against abortion but has apparently had
at least two abortions she claims to be
a devout christian but is a paid escort
to wealthy men without a license and is
too abortion she
wants to make illegal for other women
she takes money from ted cruz but
doesn't report it if she is a law and
order candidate imagine what else she'll
do to line her pockets there is clearly
no moral line mor bobert won't cross and
it's all about getting as much money as
she can not the needs of the citizens of
colorado our coalition of republicans
democrats and unaffiliated voters are
pleading with all voters in colorado's
third district to take a good long look
at lauren bobert and what she does not
what she says bobert had two abortions
but says other women cannot be able to
make this decision bobert was driving an
atv in moab and had a serious wreck with
her son in the back and her
sister-in-law is uh is so seriously
injured that she has to be flown to a
hospital via flight fight
life flight bobert doesn't report the
accident as required by utah law and
then actively works to cover up the
accident two weeks before the primary
election including pay her sister-in-law
off to remain silent bobert uses donor
money to pay her taxes and restaurant
rent which is the stuff that i was
reporting on that we covered last week
right forward still owes her employees
back pay and threatens them if they
protest again connected to the thing
that i was talking about last week jason
bobert her dick exposing husband
they didn't say that okay no that was
your comment yeah that's my company he
has he has a dick exposing right right
two miners has a consulting contract for
an oil and gas company for four hundred
and sixty thousand dollars a year but
has zero consulting experience we hope
coloradans will agree that lauren bober
doesn't deserve to represent the voters
of colorado but she does deserve being
the colorado hypocrite hall of fame for
more for more information at this uh on
this matter you can find it at
firebobert.com
can you pull can you pull that memo and
go over to the pod page and post uh some
images of that and give fire bobert and
give lincoln watchman credit since they
kind of cued us in on this um that way
our audience can take a look at it on
our pod page so go over go over to
twitter um and follow at
tony michael's pod um to see that and
also give a give a follow to lincoln
watchman and fireball bird if they have
more and more news on this you're
definitely going to want to keep up up
to speed on this and we will try to
as it breaks we will try to
bring it to you here on the show what
what a firestorm
from fire bobert right here at the end
of the show so here's the allegations
here the allegations are that that in
recent years not like um you know 10 15
years ago these are in recent years that
lauren bobert has received
side note
they also have the text messages
from who
from lauren bobert to who
to
whoever this client was whoa
it took ted cruz too because
that's that's i mean the two abortion
things honestly is not surprising the
escort thing is not surprising to me
like that she's a [ __ ] paid escort
that does not surprise me a bit does it
surprise you no no i mean here's the
thing
so you know the photos from those
websites where it's like the star talent
search one yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
they're in this
um
so that this is a getting used as a paid
escort to that oh no no sorry this is
sorry me i'm reading it through these
are text messages from their source
that says i'm sorry i'd love to help
scare you they have it on their website
there well here's here do this do this
for me so pull the pull the memo put it
on the pod page and then and and the
thread put a link to to the link here so
people can go read this and look at the
evidence for themselves yeah um so they
can see what fire board has discovered
here now that lincoln watchman and fire
bobert are posting but here's the thing
is that i'm not surprised that she's a
pay dose court because she's shame sex
work sex workers she shames people who
have anything to do with sex or the sex
industry so it's not surprising that she
was part of it and as projection it's
not surprising to me that she she calls
people who have abortions murderers and
people who who do abortions murderers
and all this nonsense because she's done
it it's not surprising to me that really
is not
the part that really gets me here is how
ted cruz is tied into this in aspen um
it appears to be that this was before
she was a congressperson um
that she met ted cruz
um
because after it acclaims after bobert
announced her campaign for congress in
december 2019 senator ted cruz donated
126 thousand dollars
to barbara's campaign to help her raise
large sums of money during trips berber
made to texas so in other words ted cruz
was paying lauren bobert's campaign to
make trips to texas
to do fundraising or whatever you know
who knows i don't know if it's
fund-raising or if it's fundraising
right well i mean rip you know i don't
know if shaker more like
maybe i don't know
right boy
you talking about that kind of
fundraising where you're yeah yeah yeah
i mean
like rudy giuliani like rudy giuliani
tucked a shirt into your balls type
fundraising right yeah holy [ __ ] it also
says bobert didn't did not disclose the
seventy five thousand dollars donated
until cruz i mean that's her election
either
of course absolutely she [ __ ] lied
why wouldn't she lie and and and all
this tying in ted cruz i think
holy moly you talk about you talking
about
baby i just want to know here's what i
want to know how many of the how many of
those two abortions was that was a
cancun abortion
right i don't know maybe maybe they took
a trip to cancun together ted cruz loves
to go to cancun maybe this is some kind
of cancun cruise abortion type thing i
don't know i'm just saying just trying
to put two and two together here ted
cruz i think that needs to be a question
that the media uh once we sniff this out
um is uh
to take cruises is one of those one of
those abortions
because of the uh
trips to texas there ted or not i don't
know you're like it's getting cold gotta
go down south right it happens
go down on someone i mean down i mean no
no down down south not down on someone
down south well
this is not surprising uh news that she
is an escort and that she's had
abortions because projection is always
with the son of a [ __ ] um the
surprising part to me is that ted cruz
is wrapped in this story and i want to
know what i want to know the question i
want to know ted cruz
is how many of these abortions
or because of trips to cancun that's all
i'm i'm just wondering maybe it's zero
maybe it's zero maybe that's the number
maybe it's one but it appears at least
one of these is from her uh work as a as
in
she talking about breaking [ __ ] news
huh god damn let's play that let's play
the little let's play the ditty here the
breaking news
breaking [ __ ] news here on the johnny
i can't wait to see i was going to tag
her in here maybe i should add her oh
tag her in that [ __ ] you goddamn right
tagger tugger rep account tag a rep yeah
that's what i wanted that's what i
wanted to do this tag or [ __ ] rip
account thanks for joining us today even
through the breaking news as we were
trying to uh
find it and sniff it out and thanks gabe
for reading us the memo and uh
you probably got it do you have a post
on the podcast page here it is now
uh i just want to make sure i got this
right hold on so go over to twitter and
follow us at the tony michaels pod you
will find the story there also don't
forget to subscribe to the tony michaels
podcast you don't want to miss any of
this breaking news as it happens we go
live every single weekday monday through
friday noon eastern 11 central nine
pacific on youtube twitter twitch and
also from the midas touch facebook page
we simulcast over there don't don't
forget tomorrow was supposed to be
the uh this the day three hearing but it
has been postponed so day three has been
moved to thursday do not forget to go to
minus touch youtube page and set a
reminder for that coverage thursday
morning we will start our coverage 9 a.m
eastern uh to gabe's chagrin six pacific
um we will be starting that coverage so
don't forget to join us
on thursday for the hearing but tomorrow
we will be here at a regular time
gabe noon eastern 11th central nine
pacific on youtube twitter twitch live
from the minus touch facebook page
simulcasting
until tomorrow surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking